quel est le sujet que vous avez pris
monsieur j'ai pris le troisième sujet
parlant du sentiment de culpabilité
vis-à-vis de m alors ne vous y croyez
individuellement ou il certainement oui
mais c'est papa vis-à-vis de la société
sera sentiment 13 individuel se
rapportant uniquement un soir pour ma
part du mois le sujet exact c'est la
volonté at elle besoin de s'appuyer sur
des habitudes et qu'en pensez vous viens
je pense que la volonté peu d'eau peut
s'appuyer sur les habitudes qu'elle a
intérêt à s'y appuyer mais qu'elle n'a
pas besoin du point de vue qualitatif
uniquement du contenu qualitatif parce
qu'elle ne veut pas couvrir tout le
champ de ton équipe notre activité quels
étaient les sujets qui étaient proposés
aux matelles m je vous mets hier c'est
plus est il qu'on nous est responsable
d'autrui le deuxième dire à l'homme
qu'il est libre s affirmer qu'il échappe
à tous à tout déterminisme c'est celui
que j'ai pris le troisième la plus la
prudence et à l'ouverture le contente on
peut rien dire je vais recadrer ou 10,2
libre j'ai dit que l'âme est tellement
fin qu'il était déterminé de toute façon
par son milieu son époque et cetera j'ai
parlé aussi du dernier scientifique qui
dit alors qu'ils enlèvent toute liberté
à l'homme il est des sujets
attendez je voulais de neige celle alors
on avait une explication de texte de
quand un texte entre la différence à la
supériorité de la machine sur l'homme
vous y croyez non pas tellement élevé
elle vous avez choisi le troisième soit
il souhaitable que l'homme ne fut pas
accessible aux patients puisque vous
avez dit en gros
chez moi personnellement je pense que
l'homme ne t'a pas accessible aux
patients
[Musique]
anna massey à différents quels sujets
vous avez choisi sur la passion la
passion qu'est ce que vous avez dit oh
que je suive tout prix mais en gros
votre idée l'homme est il accessible aux
passions c'est ça oui vous pensez je me
suis enfui
jusqu'au point
puis lentement n'est pas tellement
connaissance alors
le dernier
buteur puisque les sas était sortie
avait fait l'année dernière l'année
dernière il y avait
un
raisonnement était toujours de nature
mathématiques
ya à peu près toujours une question de
logique nous sommes pas macho mais
toujours les passions de cours à 7 ans
lui avait facilité et demi avec
cambiasso
appelé le problème de la raison monde
c'est à dire le nez c'était universel
ce matin ce qu'est la physique et balla
lô
et qu'est ce que j'avais choisi comme
sujet au basson jury sur le sur l'art on
avait deux trois sujets sur l'art sur
l'histoire et un sur rousseau le sujet
seront ce n'est pas chaque pas tellement
j'aime pas les commentaires ce difficile
je t'ai pas mal c'était sûr
et à la liberté vous avez noirci combien
de feuilles ou une feuille ses défunts
je trouve que c'est bien pour moi
d'habitude
je suis une demie les élèves ont planché
sur des sujets comme l'histoire est-elle
notre mémoire collective la mathématique
et l réductible à la logique ou bien le
fait de parler la même langue institut
t-il entre les hommes des liens
privilégiés autant de questions
auxquelles il a fallu répondre
alors vous êtes sorti près d'une demi
heure en avance ce j'en conclus que ça
s'est bien passé pas exactement peut pas
trop savoir en philo vous avez choisi
l'histoire tel notre mémoire collective
alors j'ai répondu positivement
je pense m'en être sorti
c'est pas mal passé dans l'ensemble il
se trouve que
je m'attendais pas un sujet aussi facile
quand même
mais
j'aurais pu je pense faire mieux
avec oman donc
l'expérience immédiate est elle source
de vérité
l'inconscient intime en moi nature ou
histoire et puis un texte est ce qui
nous a insultés en bâtiment
quels sujets vous avez choisi de
troisième explication de texte c'était
les états démocratiques et pas tout seul
peut-être totalité à part dont les
stations j'ai beaucoup aimé ça vous
inspire
aux couches francs copie douvres tout le
monde a choisi le commentaire je pense à
toi je pense pas qu'on s'attendait à ça
qu on suggère et vous attendiez à quoi
alors nous on avait pensé se retrouver
là pourquoi bah on avait pas mal de vent
peut développer ça enfonce donc
j'avais encore et est pleine la mangue
papaye pas
vraiment content ugg fait les choses
humaines peuvent-elles adopter les
méthodes des sciences de la nature
en gros je me suis planté
j'ai choisi comme sujet le sujet numéro
un sur
la conscience de soi si ça craint
dites-moi la crise du golfe ça va pas un
peu figurer dans les sujets la paire
jean violence ou les guerres toutes les
formes de violence possible et que socke
fait nous poser on pense que ça risque
de tomber vous avez presque tout faux
mademoiselle seules les séries b auront
droit à un texte de cannes sur le droit
et l'état tous les autres ont blêmit sur
des questions aussi classique que
redoutable que diriez vous si on vous
demandait l'homme pourrait-il vivre sans
conscience du passé 1 à tout hasard moi
je dirais non et vous ben moi j'ai dit
que qui pouvait pas bien sûr c'est un
peu sec comme réponse mais c'était un
sujet difficile or il y avait le choix
on peut voir vos impressions là ça a
marché on verra au résultat s'est choisi
le beau et le beau s
vous savez la philo ça fait deux je le
sujet c'était le beauf le bo est il
nécessaire on faisait très beau à votre
caméra vous êtes fort utile non je sais
pas moyen d s'en fout il faut dire que
pour ces élèves de sections
scientifiques les philo n'est que
coefficient 3 en revanche pour les
candidats qui viennent des classes
littéraires on passe à un coefficient 7
les sujets distribués ce matin semble
avoir intéressé nombre d'entre eux
pleins évoqué la force de démonstration
le second poser la question peut-on dire
d'un acte qu'il est inhumain et le
troisième c'était puis-je faire
confiance à mes sens un thème qui semble
avoir reçu pas mal de succès jeudi que
qu'on ne pouvait pas avoir totalement
confiance en nos sens j'ai parlé de la
raison et de kant qu'en fait je dis que
les sens c'était simplement
quelque sorte un tremplin j'ai dit que
je pouvais pas faire confiance confiance
à ce sens parce que c'était une
certitude sensible et que donc c'était
quand on est tous là quoi j'ai ressorti
le court maintenant faut voir vous êtes
contente de vous non pourquoi parce que
j'avais des bonnes notes au refus
l'autre que je pense pas que ce sera
génial mais ne vous inquiétez pas
mademoiselle il y a toujours pire que
soit voilà à copier blangy
jessica pourraz de chanter
mais bon voilà quoi c'est le bac 1 ça
fait partie du bac comme quoi même si on
est nul en philo on peut toujours être
philosophe c'est en candidat libre comme
on a travaillé toute l'année on va
essayer de leur passé alors vous sentez
bien quand même pas du tout pas du tout
moi je me sens bien
le bac c'est dans la poche dans la poche
facile à dire il ya quand même quatre
heures d'épreuve avec quelques questions
fondamentales qui suis-je la vérité de
l'opinion la connaissance du réel où la
liberté il est presque midi premières
impressions s'était très bien passé ça
s'est très bien passé je suis assez
contente maintenant on attend dehors ils
sont déjà nombreux à s'attendre pour
s'interroger discuter et confronter
leurs points de vue
écoutez ça va c'est pas si terrible que
ça en fait en fait on nous a trop monté
la tête pendant l'année le bac le bac le
bac mais quand on y arrive c'est un
contrôle de quatre heures on en fait
tout un bon j'ai pas un sujet très
facile à la question qui suivent puis
j'ai apporté une réponse exacte
et j'ai peur d'avoir fait un contresens
sur exact de 8h à 12h les candidats avec
quatre heures pour disserter faut-il
préférer le bonheur à la vérité n'avons
nous de voir qu'anvers autrui
l'expérience peut être démontré quelque
chose autant de sujets qui en on doit
goûter certains
9h30 celui là dans mes deux premiers à
sortir
10h45 celui-ci à tout employé pas
pourquoi as tu eu plus longtemps que je
n'ai pas réussi à être plus d'idées on
verra sa ligne 12 heures l'épreuve est
terminée pour tout le monde première
impression première et c'est
parce que je connaissais pas du tout sûr
je sais pas
notamment pour fidji en revanche les
astres ont semble-t-il était plus
clément ça va c'était abordable
maintenir l essor du cpe ça s'est plutôt
bien passé
je suis plutôt inquiet je me dis on a
pas finis les programmes et où on a fini
in extremis
le jour du bac tout est permis l'habit
fait tilt lemoine ça aurait d'ailleurs
pu être un bon sujet pour ce jeune homme
raté en philosophie ce matin
ses élèves de terminales scientifiques
ont dû plancher sur l'art peut-il se
passer de règles ou encore dépend-il de
nous d'être heureux alors quatre heures
plus tard verdict dépend il de nous
d'être heureux j'ai d'abord dit lui même
réélu non parce qu'il ya des désirs on
peut paramétrer les deux équipes puisque
le
et à besançon on respire l'épreuve la
plus redoutée est passé soulagé d'avoir
fini la première épreuve là des choses à
dire mais c'est quand même pas facile
quoi pour les littéraires coefficient 7
et deux sujets faut-il oublier le passé
pour se donner un avenir où la recherche
de la vérité peut-elle être
désintéressée
je sais que ça allait tourner sur
l'intention sur le droit la politique ou
sur le langage mais je pensais pas du
tout sûr les temps je viens pour nous
mêmes nous le passé le présent et le
futur c'est un sujet qui nous touche r
[Musique]